so we have two pieces of information
here we're told that 11 is equal to 8
plus f inverse of x minus 3 and that f
of 3 is equal to 10.
what i would like you to try is pause
the video and figure out the value of x
so i'm
it looks a little daunting at first
you're like wow f inverse of x minus
three and whenever you see something
like this at least my impulse is at
least just try to simplify the
information you have and then see if we
can make sense of it
so here we can definitely simplify this
equation by subtracting 8 from both
sides
just so that we have f inverse by itself
on one side
so if we subtract 8 from both sides the
left hand side 11 minus 8 is 3
and the right hand side is f inverse of
x
minus 3. or i could write this as
f inverse of x minus 3
is equal to
3.
so these are these are essentially our
two pieces of information once we
simplify
this over here and this seems pretty
interesting because we say f of 3 is 10
and then we're saying f inverse so f
inverse of this right over here is equal
to 3. so there seems to be something
interesting going on so we could even
just think about what a function and
inverse does
so this is the domain of the function
domain
and if this is the range
this is the range
we know that the function maps from 3 in
the domain
to 10 in the range
to 10 in the range that's what the
function does but if the function does
that then the inverse function would map
from 10 in the range
to 3 in the domain
so this would be f
inverse so f inverse of 10 is equal to
3. let me write that down f inverse of
is equal to 3.
so what this thing right over here is
the same thing as that thing right over
here
so 10 10 must be equal to x minus 3.
so we could write x minus 3 is equal to
add 3 to both sides x is equal to
x is equal to 13.